[Music]
in lazy afford the wind news I love
being lazy don't you yes lazy so fun yes
submitted by Gina will love this oh yeah
I've found a service that comes to your
house to wash your car for you that's
dull how much is that it was lazy dude I
got braces not even stepping foot in a
Adonis oh that I love like someone comes
and picks up my laundry does it for me
gets delivered to me I'm gonna wash my
car any more efficient that's awesome
true for me it's like it's like time is
money and you can save me time I'm doing
it when you go motorized wheelchair that
[Laughter]
people just like I will be the first
person in that [ __ ] wheelchair in
wall-e
yeah I'll judge you then but right now
you're fine I like controlled laziness
we're like it's like rewarded laziness
where you can just binge on [ __ ] or like
you knows something's gonna go down so
like you just do a lot of work to
motivate yourself and you just [ __ ]
binge Lee yeah yeah yeah new research
suggests the evolution might favor
survival of the laziest thank you I will
live forever
that's that makes total sense because on
interest maybe people end up being
sometimes smarter they're efficient
efficient cuz they don't want to do
anything and you know what we don't do
we don't go [ __ ] BASE jumping and
[ __ ] we stay in our room where it's nice
and safe and cozy well how are you gonna
get booze if you don't call BASE jumping
it's fine don't worry about it I'll
figure it out smell that's just
physically lazy I'm talking about like
mentally lazy I forgot who I was I think
I might have been Steve Jobs but I heard
of some like super rich person they only
like they like to hire only lazy people
because they find the quickest solutions
to those problems
yes okay so I've always said I've always
said to have a successful business you
have to cater to people's vanity or
laziness for Instagram is vanity
laziness is
convenience everything that's right oh
my my crew whenever we're working I'm
just like I'm [ __ ] lazy I don't want
to do this work so I'm trying to find
the easiest way to systemize things so
I'm like done so that's where the term
were Tinley smarter not harder
mm-hm comes in delicious truly easy is
don't do anything at all I'm so
responsible though yeah I said done but
I find the quickest way that's not real
laziness
that's responsibility lazy lazy lazy
it's not showering for a month and
letting all your dishes and cups pile up
yeah but my lazy ass pay someone to do
it lazy and motivated yes lazy and
motivator yeah that's lazy and
irresponsible but because they're
responsible that's just homeless because
if you like it if you let the dishes
pile up but you're aggressively playing
video games are not really lazy
that's pretty nervous because you still
have effort but I just put somewhere
else you know what homeless does you
mean you lazy that you because I just
realized that some of the guys that
stand in Little Tokyo like a lot of shop
guys like we're friends and big tell me
some of them make buddies in one day I'm
Tarek and you got to repeat the same
line like twelve thousand times there's
a big article for Cisco that's not lazy
at all I can't say the same line twelve
thousand times I tell myself I used to
do that for [ __ ] Telemark oh my god
Lori I'm like I gotta say the same [ __ ]
over over over over over [ __ ] that yeah
so recently this study was published in
the Proceedings of the Royal Society B
by a research team thank you
it sounds to the Royal Society Society
beans I just met mine feel like a really
fancy being with a little crown on yeah
I saw though beehive yeah so of his
research teams based at the University
of
Kansas and they were looking at a period
of roughly five million years give or
take yes roughly
let's give or take five million years
the researchers they analyzed two
hundred ninety-ninth species is
metabolic rate I was just talking to
David about this Dam which means that
aren't like it's the amount of energy
that that we're gonna organism need to
live so they're taking the biological
approaches so what they found is that
the higher metabolic rates so the
organisms that use way more energy they
are way more likely to go extinct duh
duh David like tweeted something out and
he was talking about like Oh David so
this result and he said something he
said something about like oh I look at a
burger and get fat or whatever he's
talking something I was like that's cuz
your calorie efficient the calories you
eat your body uses if you don't like
using you store and that's why you get
more fun so high metabolism people are
gonna die out yeah way more effort dude
that's actually not efficient
yeah they're way more [ __ ] but
they're actually less efficient or less
efficient lovers I always knew I was
you're dead you're dead skinny sorry you
just seem like you just you know you
just don't do [ __ ] no cuz it cuz it cuz
if we're talking physiologically
metabolic then you're you're still just
gonna burn the way more even though that
ratio is pretty small what if you had
high metabolism like all throughout life
and in your 30s hit and then you don't
yeah I think though even the range is
smaller people think yeah how does it
work yeah it's actually not it's
actually not that your metabolism is a
drop like that it's your change in
lifestyle yeah makes you think that so I
may be winner in her twenties driving
around all over the place going to club
here what club over there so your
caloric expenditures are way higher you
just think of millet table some drop the
sister just sitting around three meals a
day now back down a pile a one yeah cuz
I was broke as [ __ ] so I ate less back
then and you would dance a lot right oh
yeah that's right I dance so much holy
[ __ ] that's right three times a week or
more I did three times a week for an
hour use pound where you left 100
it was in those pants hours straight for
like three nights a week and it was
always in like hot sweaty nightclubs and
[ __ ]
yes Allah so high metabolism people are
more like energetic they're less energy
efficient which makes them die off
according to the society mmm I could see
that because the moment I wake up I
[ __ ] waste so much energy doing all
kinds of [ __ ] movements yeah man I do
I have extra body movements all the time
like Wiggly legs arms shaky ass feet
that might be different than like pure
genetics so - you might want to get that
looked at yeah restless legs and so it's
just but so there's no they don't know
the causation they're just saying over
the course of five million years is
whatever species that have a higher
metabolic rate they just tend to die out
sooner that and if they are all
concentrated in one region they are more
likely to be extinct I see they need to
spread that [ __ ] all over the world I
wonder what that's like for other
animals like you hear about whales
eating whatever billion pounds of food a
[ __ ] day or whatever but like what
animal doesn't eat much with the pandas
yeah they just need like one sheet of
bamboo a day and be done no they have to
eat like non-stop bamboo like all day
long but then there's like so little
nutrients what's the opposite something
in like the desert they you like once a
month snakes like a turtle a desert
tortoise yeah maybe maybe they once yeah
they look turtle yep Turtles I am going
to lose forever that's your spirit
animal it no the spirit animal for me
it's jellyfish because I'm dangerous oh
they float around they don't do [ __ ] all
day and all day you know they just eat
and look pretty and if someone comes
near them there's an immortal jellyfish
they don't know he's one species of it
yeah it's called the immortal jellyfish
and they just don't die ya know yeah
they just read their cells just keep
regenerating I don't believe it
they study them we're trying to probably
be human you guys are all on fake news
no way
so if something doesn't eat this thing
he's gonna live five million years same
thing with the lobster I know the name
you call me immortal Mike doesn't mean
I'm going to live to it there's that one
a tiny little thing to that I can live
through like radiation and sub-zero
temperatures oh yeah no it was like a
little organism it looked like a little
caterpillar yeah he's fat yeah I don't
see anything that says live for goddamn
ever yeah life cycle let me say race
infinity it's just as long as it could
it's just gonna infinite eyes yeah it
just it just keeps me [ __ ] Juba
native is illogical immortality the
cells just keep going on lifespan which
varies by species from hours to many
months so then according to a study ship
it sucks yeah I don't want to meet that
jellyfish so according to this study uh
they're saying that it's just better for
you to be leave they're not saying it's
individually they're talking about
species why there's a giant umbrella
statement and then how can I make this
click baby for someone to understand
like a sloth versus like individuals as
well how can they say that I don't know
it says here that the strategy for
survival of individual species and even
communal communities of species that's
what the they were researching because
what they're what it looks like is they
observed so if it's an observation
conclusion they're just observing that
yeah throughout the years species that
burn less calories lasted longer but
they haven't tested that theory on
individual so they don't really have
conclusions I just want more articles
that support laziness because this day
and age everyone is always like work
card hashtag hustle and then like
everyone feeds into that [ __ ] and then
people don't prize laziness when most of
us are or I just wanna say yeah
I just want to feel good for Who I am I
just want to yeah I agree I want people
to be lazy so I don't have to work hard
like it yeah cut the standards down no
one goes to the gym anymore if you don't
do that don't do that
no okay imagine this if if a 15 minute
mile is considered really good we just
have to run it in 14 yeah I'm gonna
consider Usain Bolt but because there's
people that run four-minute miles out
there lowers the standard yeah if you
graduate third grade and you're a genius
I'll just graduate fourth grade yeah
people will still go to the gym it's
just like it's like instead of seven
days a week
the max would be three or five yeah why
is that bad but monthly memberships the
same amount of money we'll check the
what teams will change the marketing a
little bit okay yeah let me set the
quota I will put the bar literally on
the ground yeah the whole study though
it wasn't on humans it was like Oh
mollusks and gastropods in the Atlantic
Ocean that's what they were mainly
studying an immortal jellyfish
supposedly I would like to think that
it's for humans that's why they're
making headlines right now I'm going to
think it's for humans and make myself
feel better what makes me so angry is
that people that work hard make me feel
like I have to get off my ass so if
everybody was like we just need to
create something like a society where
everyone gets things just paid like
equally so we don't have to take care of
ourselves
and then and then we're all equally lazy
and we're all you know I'm gonna run it
I'm gonna run everyone gets a trophy
because everyone's special and then like
when people work too hard you say hey
dude chill chill chill like a union you
know like like where we all do the same
thing together sounds exactly like you
let's all be useless together
[Music]